I want to bring in mark Travis the CEO
of intrepid capital where he manages
over a billion dollars actually mark
let's let's get your take on this icon
versus Fink who do you who do you side
with well I think this is a beauty of an
indexed world betty-lou you know with a
eat ETFs and Larry Fink's prominence in
that part of the business we no longer
care what a business costs or what
management does just so long as it's
part of the index you have to buy it and
I'm guessing he just has to vote who
shares accordingly so you know I think
if you go in any Holdings on hds page in
Bloomberg right now you know Blackrock
is one of the bigger holders because of
the peripheral a proliferation excuse me
it's early in the morning of ETFs and
this index Oh save it and forget it
that's why bot why bother just see what
it looks like an index and you know go
play golf like you mark okay I'm a
terrible golfer penniless all right I
hang on one second mark because I want
to bring in a Mike Regan who is our US
stocks editor i forgot to mention that
you are joining us at all like a
question for mark well I sort of caught
by something else icon said which is
that you know so many people have loaded
into high-yield debt and if it there
really is any sign of weakness in that
space that there'll be I think his quote
was a run for the exits and I know
intrepid has a pretty good steak in
oaktree capital which invests in a lot
of high-yield debt so I'm curious why
you think of that is you know a
potential rate increase potentially
going to cause a run for the exit or
what is your take on the future in that
space well Mike I think that credit
spreads are very low in that part of the
world and financial assets i think you
know we're we're not quite to where we
were in june of 07 right before things
went bump in the night with the bear
stearns mortgage-backed fun and kind of
set all the fun off but you know I'm
kind of the belief that we've boxed
ourselves in or the Fed has in what
we've borrowed they've allowed the you
know congressional leaders to get by
with their Pro Phil go see because of
cheap rates
and now we've borrowed so much money we
can't afford to pay it back and not only
can we not afford to pay it back we
can't afford a higher rate on it so you
know I think it's going to be a long
time coming but you know as I mentioned
with the Bear Stearns mortgage-backed
funding July of seven things can happen
that we we can't foresee from right here
yeah but but I think Howard Marks at oak
tree will be ready and able to take
advantage of the dislocations as will
hope to do at intrepid capital so you
know we were all talking about reading
did you mark read bill gross's letter it
was it came out today his outlook for
you so he sounds depressed he died i
said bob out there with my yeah yeah so
some sound looks a bit so Betty what
part of depressed with a your own fund
with seven hundred million dollars in it
so he said well good point okay so he
says what he says the super cycle and
bull market is over right what else did
he say yeah I don't like he thinks he's
over yeah I mean I know luck thing on
his own death is is it's a pretty
shocking shocking commentary right well
actually work AC he says quote I have a
sense of any of an ending a secular bull
market ending with a whimper not a bang
I have unrest increasingly a great
unrest you should as well well but you
know sounds like he rests well at night
he said he doesn't beep kind of I've am
he's resting Hines well okay good for
him mark what do you think of that well
again I pity bill for you know with as
much money as he has that he's he's
depressed and you know I think you can
get a bear market in time I guess maybe
that's what he's inferring I mean we
certainly had a bull market financial
assets particularly the last you know 36
months I mean look at 13 and 14 took the
FSP up fifty percent so you know I don't
think prices are compellingly cheap and
they could they could stay somewhat
elevated and not drop precipitously but
not really make any forward progress so
who knows what bills thinking but he's
right you know he's gonna be okay oh
yeah right oh he'll be fine I don't know
what it's fun he can't take it with him
I think it's what he's trying to say
right exactly okay but you know I think
but mark one of the things you mentioned
too because you're worried about whether
the feds box the men is whether this
bull market is it you know it's kind of
coming to an end here itself right
whether it's getting a little bit long
in the tooth I don't know if it ends
with a whimper instead of a battle will
be okay what we don't want is another
bang yeah and I think that you know
taking some volatility out of it that
that would be fine it's just the bangs
or what we don't need we've already had
two of those in the last dozen years and
they are awful yeah but think about all
the things that happen that we couldn't
foreseen I mean think about the flash
crash guy with a fat finger on a button
and all sudden vaporize you know a
couple trillion dollars or who would
have thought a couple of Nobel Prize
winners would blow up a hedge fund and
you know September at 98 I mean or the
United Airlines merger wouldn't happen
in 1990 and the market is cracked I mean
there's so many things that can happen
and when you've got cheap money like we
have you've got people levered
significantly in margin debt in other
ways and you know it who knows where
it'll come from so wait so so so mark
what are you you know what keeps that
sounds like you're worried about that
he's worried about it you're worried
about a bang and not a whimper um yeah I
mean you know I prepare that prices can
actually go down on any given day and I
like to have cash available to take
advantage of those dislocations as I
like to say to be fully invested today
means there's no better opportunity
tomorrow and that's not assumption we
make an intrepid kapil all right mark
thank you so mark mark Travis of
intrepid capital